it's saturday morning english lessons at
the yatanabon orphanage it's a new
situation for the over one hundred boys
there
volunteers like sue suezin
are teaching them the 26 year old has
organized the project the orphans are to
have classes at least once a week
the orphanage was founded by a buddhist
monk it relies on donations
these boys are on kitchen duty
the monks only eat once a day even the
kids have just the basics there's no
money for schooling
i really want to
fulfill their
needs i mean when i say their needs like
such as like teaching like their food
clothes
uh
maybe i might probably ask other people
for donate
uh for this orphanage yeah i would try
to do as much as i can yeah
okay
apart from the monks there's no one to
look after the children that's why they
need the help of volunteers
each child has one box containing
everything that they own
but now they have sue and the other
volunteers
for them taking responsibility
championing equality in myanmar seems
natural here again next saturday
saying
myanmar is still one of the poorest
countries in southeast asia
but political freedoms are growing
even the economy is opening up
younger burmese in particular are
seizing the opportunities
a meeting of kindred spirits
sue has just joined the local global
shaper network it was founded a few
months ago and has 10 members
it receives advice from the world
economic forum in switzerland which has
experience and expertise
all three volunteers have studied abroad
now they want to have their say in
myanmar and shape the country
i think it's a crucial time in our
history
and we need as much brain power as much
skills as much professional
uh power that we can get every great
country they did not start with one
person
so they start with the one team
so that's that's this must be 18. so
that's what i want to do because i want
to i want to create my uh great the
community attend a better team and you
know i just uh by doing that i do
believe that our country will be slowly
pick up you know
the global shapers are under 30 years
old and they believe that a lot needs to
be changed for instance the gap between
rich and poor
pai is an entrepreneur and trades in
rice his parents gave him the initial
start-up money today he heads a small
company in rangoon it's not easy the
stakes are high
on this day there's another power
blackout that means the machines can't
run
daily laborers are recruited to carry
the 50 kilogram sacks
pie wants to encourage other young
entrepreneurs like himself
i always want to share my experience and
knowledge with other people because you
know some of the people are new they are
kind of afraid to share their own
knowledge because they thought that that
person might over what would take him
but in my case it's a different story
you know the ocean is there's a lot of
fish
pai is 29 years old his workers are only
a few years younger
the businessman knows his country needs
jobs and incomes for people he's working
tirelessly to make that a reality
his next project is to expand the mobile
phone network in his country
you